[Music]
[Applause]
I forgot that Andrew Dice Clay was in a
stars born with Bradley Cooper and Lady
Gaga and U he played the father of Lady
Gaga and and he's been in a few movies
and I even forgot How big Ford Fairlane
was when it came out it's like this guy
we got to capitalize on his Fame because
it happened overnight um Entourage he
was in Entourage as well so he's had
quite a few acting gigs and then I think
he's doing some standup now a little bit
more he's going to be at the wilter in
Los Angeles that'll be November 15th I
think that's where it all started like
one of his first shows that he ever did
Andrew Dice Clay's new basketball film
Warrior strong came out September 29th
available wherever you buy or rent
movies Andrew Dice
Clay um is the movie is it a serious
movie or a funny
movie there's some humor in it but it's
absolutely a story about these kids in
in a in a in a high school and you know
I don't want to give away the plot of
the movie but it's a story of you know
them triumphing and becoming a team and
working together and you know it's that
kind of thing I just don't want to give
away the whole story
Adam Sandler talked about when he does a
serious role like it always surprises
people you know like punch drunk love uh
you know my favorite out of every Sanda
movie ever you know and I've told them
this I could every time I see punch
drunk love you know you know when I'm
watching if if I'm flipping the channels
and it's pun I watch it yeah to me
that's his best role I mean I Lov uncut
gems he was great in that too but punch
drunk please to it I don't know if you
did any acting in in your past in your
youth but you know to turn into that
kind of character every day just to me
you know he should have just maybe he
did win an award for it but he was
amazing but are you acting when you did
your standup are you are you being a
character well you know it's a it's a
side of me you know I've been asked this
my whole life you know who's Andrew
Who's d like right now I'm more Andrew
than dice I'm not on stage now but you
know I'm a Brooklyn guy so I grew up
watching you know all these these types
of guys and as my comedy developed you
know I become more Brooklyn like the
edgy edgy side of me me that would come
out on stage you know and you know my
comedy you know it was always you know I
always say Lenny Bruce said it best when
he goes you know all comedy should be is
we we're a mirror of what goes on in the
world you know the mirror of what people
do and I do believe in in a lot of Truth
on stage talking to Andrew Dice Clay new
basketball film Warrior strong just came
out on SE member 29th and available
where you buy or rent movies when did
you know you were a
star
um well I knew
when see the acting thing started taking
off you know I did a Michael Man series
called crime story and it just wasn't
getting the ratings and I remember
Michael man talking about cancelling it
so and he goes all right tell me why I
can't cancel the show I go
okay you give me a few months I'm gonna
be the biggest star in the world he goes
oh really that's nice to hear you know I
go I just shot this Rodney
Dangerfield young comedian special and
when it is you know I'm G to blow I'll
be the biggest comic in the world and
you'll have one of the biggest stars in
the world on your television show so so
he's looking at me now Michael's a lot
older than me you know especially back
then I was like about I don't know I
think I was still 28 years old he's
looking at me and he goes he goes look
dice he goes I love you as an actor you
know and I think you have a future as an
actor and I wish you a lot of luck with
this Rodney Dangerfield skit that you
did but you know uh it's a very
expensive show to shoot and uh you know
you're get in the pink slip that's it
the show goes off the air within
weeks um the Rodney special is three
months later on a Saturday night and
Monday I'm the biggest comic in the
world I mean within months I was you
know I was selling out Arenas within I
don't know 20 30 minutes you know it it
was just it that's why they called it
Dice Man back then and I remember
running into Michael man about two years
into that at a party and he grabs me and
he goes let me ask you something if you
were me Michael man Miami Vice and he
named some of the movies he's done at
the time and you got some kid telling
you be the biggest star in the world
what would you have said you know and I
I agreed with him you know but I I just
love the show so much I wanted to keep
it on there you know and you know here I
am years later still with the standup
this is what's nuts then um so you know
I I I became you know the last I don't
know few years you know I do a thing
called Club dice I do anything from 300
seats to 3,000 seats which are theaters
and you know Club dice is is the most
expensive ticket
in comedy club history they charge like
to $200 a ticket for a comedy club that
might get $30 $40 at the door for a a
kind of big headliner the thing that
started this whole thing in me a friend
of mine was in town my f one my my
favorite comic Bill bar was playing an
arena out in Jersey in
Newark and you know so I said to my
girlfriend I said you want to go see
Bill b let's go you know know I'd love
to see his whole show in a you know cuz
I never go to shows I just don't and so
I go to the show and I'm teasing her on
the way you know and I'm go oh I haven't
done an arena in 23 years she you know
because I love to tease her and she's
going you're not performing you're just
going to see the guy because I know I'm
just teasing her the second I walk into
his dressing room he gets up he's got
this smile on his face and he goes he
gets right in my face he goes you're
going to do some time tonight right dice
oh and my
insides started churning you know what I
mean I'm like no I'm just I'm here to
see you he goes no you you're gonna do
some
time and I'm like what am I gonna say no
so I'm like all right I got to do this
you know and and I'll be honest it was
frightening to me I hadn't done
something like this in years so I get
announced and the minute I was announced
the place exploded and once I was on
that stage and I saw that crowd I could
have done two hours okay so you know I
got to thank bill for this because now a
few weeks later which is only a few
weeks ago I get a text on a Monday night
11:30 at night from the road manager
Guns and Roses they're playing the
metti stadium on
Tuesday they want me to go on because
right now a lot of things are very
nostalgic yeah and but we're not talking
about you know 15 or 20,000 people
you're talking about
60,000 you know and even my girlfriend
who said after the bill bir thing she
goes you see you can do it is sitting on
the couch with me going you know you
don't have to do this so I go no I do
have to do it so next thing you know
it's like a minute went by and now I'm
backstage and as I'm walking I start
hearing the crowd The Pretenders were
already on and now I start seeing the
stadium of
people okay so I'm standing there and
now I hear the guy introduce me and the
crowd starts to yell but when they saw
me they just went ballistic
how often do people come up to you and
then they want to recite your nursery
rhymes like the guy we have here fritzy
fritzy would you like to give dice a
little
dice hey didd didd the cats in the
fiddle the cow jumped over the moon
that's more than my wife ever does that
lazy fat baboon oh you guys are
unbelievable
[Laughter]
oh no but I do you know talking about
material I close every show
with the nursery rhymes like all the
materials new but I closed the show
because it it's such like like fritzy
just did it is such a famous signature
piece for a comic and I think what makes
it famous is that the audiences have
always done it with me so if you don't
do it no matter how good the show is
they'll walk out saying I like the show
but how come he didn't do the poems so I
always make sure to do it I love how did
fritzy do there dice fritzy did pretty
good I liked it you know he could be a
little deeper in the voice when he does
it oh okay you know little deeper fritzy
fritzy can you do a little deeper same
one the other ones are pretty runchy
though yeah exactly exactly all right
work on little boy blue he needed the
money
oh all right now I got to say the o
bothered me a
little oh no you know here like Let Let
me let me do all right here we go little
boy blo he needed the money
oh you gotta draw it
out you gotta s fabulous the is what
they wait
for you
understand I can't possibly duplicate
that I grew up watching him that
dangerfields concert was amazing the
first time I saw him good to talk to you
good luck with the movie and the standup
uh in that'll be in November at the
wilter in Los Angeles November 15th on
sale right now the State Theater and Pa
you know what to do I gotta tell you
oh thank you Dice thank you very much
Andrew Dice Clay the new basketball film
Warrior strong it came out September
29th available wherever you buy or rent
mov mov is also performing at the wilter
in Los Angeles November 15th